[Music]
governments around the world are quickly
responding to a new covet variant which
health officials fear could be more
dangerous than the delta that's
currently the dominant strain right here
in the u.s natalie brand in washington
now with response from health officials
[Applause]
the dow jones plunged more than 900
points on black friday amid global fears
of a potentially dangerous new strain of
the
today coronavirus your response to that
they always do
the world health organization has
designated the newly named omicron
variant first detected in south africa a
variant of concern because of mutations
that scientists fear could make it more
transmissible than the delta variant and
able to evade current vaccine
protections this variant has a large
number of mutations
and the concern is that when you have so
many mutations it can have an impact on
how the virus behaves president biden
has been briefed on the new variant and
the administration's health officials
say they've been in contact with their
south african counterparts to learn as
much about it as possible we don't know
a lot about the very end except that it
is a great concern
the biden administration announced it
will join asian and european countries
in restricting travel for people coming
from south african countries starting
monday i spent about a half hour this
morning with my cover team led by
dr
so that was the decision
pfizer tells cbs news it's expected to
take up to two weeks to determine if its
vaccine is effective against the new
variant natalie brandt cbs news the
white house